a participant in one of my online
courses had a great question he wanted
to know if they lack flexibility in his
wrist could make this pattern difficult
and I get this kind of question a lot if
people who are bigger sometimes wonder
if that makes patterns difficult and
people of different injuries relax lack
of flexibility and the answer is it can
make patterns a little harder but I
think usually how you move your body and
your control over the plains is a much
bigger factor let me show you what I
mean if I stand very still with my body
behind me that takes a lot of
flexibility I have to move according to
the central line of my body the central
plains I have to move my hand behind my
shoulder and I myself have a very hard
time getting my hands back there so
takes a lot of work and it doesn't feel
very good but if I control my body with
this movement and I can subtly bend the
plane as it goes front to back check
this out
technically my hand is actually far in
front of my shoulder but I'm moving my
body which makes the hand move from the
front plane to the back plane and I can
relax my shoulders quite a bit and I can
hold they make that pattern work from
the front it looks like this so this
takes much less flexibility but it takes
more control over the planes and over
moving my body and I really rhythmic and
coordinated way but I can do it here I
can reach up I can reach out I can if I
do that it's gonna be a little more
flexibility but all of this doesn't have
to take much flexibility it does take
plane control and it does take learning
to move your body like this in time with
the poi which actually takes a lot of
practice so if you think lack
flexibility is slowing you down it's
possible that's true but often you can
overcome it
with planes in body control I hope
that's helpful and by the way this is
the pool at wild savage I am the
resident boy teacher until June 2019 and
I plan to be back for the following
season December to May or June next
years as well in fact I hope to continue
that year after year so you can come
play pool with me here and you can see
oka and we can even go paddleboarding
[Music]